แม้คอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมจะไม่เหมาะกับทุกปัญหา
แต่มีปัญหาบางประเภทและ use case บางอย่าง
ที่เราคาดว่าการคำนวณควอนตัม
จะสร้างความเปลี่ยนแปลงได้
ซึ่งรวมถึงการจำลอง เช่น
การสร้างแบบจำลองกระบวนการและระบบที่เกิดขึ้นใน
ธรรมชาติ การค้นหาและการ optimization
ที่เกี่ยวกับการหาคำตอบที่ดีที่สุดหรือ
คำตอบที่ optimal ในสถานการณ์ที่มี
คำตอบที่เป็นไปได้มากมาย และคณิตศาสตร์
และการประมวลผลข้อมูลที่มีโครงสร้างซับซ้อน
รวมถึงการประยุกต์ใช้กับ machine learning
quantum algorithm ใช้แนวทางใหม่ในการแก้
ปัญหาประเภทนี้ โดยใช้ประโยชน์จาก
คุณสมบัติเฉพาะของฟิสิกส์ควอนตัม เช่น
superposition, interference และ entanglement
คอมพิวเตอร์ทั่วไปติดขัด
เมื่อต้องสำรวจบางส่วนของพื้นที่การคำนวณ
จึงไม่สามารถค้นหารูปแบบเหล่านั้นได้
คอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมมีความสามารถพิเศษ
หรือประสิทธิภาพที่สูงกว่า
สำหรับบางปัญหาที่ได้จากคุณสมบัติควอนตัมของมัน
เพื่อเข้าใจศักยภาพของคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมอย่างถ่องแท้
ต้องศึกษาทฤษฎีความซับซ้อนเชิงการคำนวณอย่างลึกซึ้ง
ซึ่งเป็นสาขาหนึ่งของวิทยาการคอมพิวเตอร์ที่เน้น
การวัดและเปรียบเทียบความพยายามเชิงการคำนวณที่
ต้องใช้ในการแก้ปัญหาประเภทต่างๆ
สิ่งนี้ให้กรอบแนวคิดที่มีประโยชน์
สำหรับอธิบายการเร่งความเร็วในรูปแบบต่างๆ
และประเภทของปัญหาที่พบเจอใน
การคำนวณ